[Musique]
c'est une alerte ou danser il ya
quelques semaines par bercy les
entreprises françaises stratégiques
pourraient être menacés d'une prédation
en provenance de l'étranger
le chef du service de l'information
stratégique et de la sécurité économique
à bercy geoffrey célestin urbain l'a
affirmé il ya quelques semaines alors
que la france et le monde entier sont
plongés dans l'une des plus fortes
crises économiques de l'histoire
certains pays grandes puissances
économiques pouvant parfois même être
des alliés se sont relevés plus vite que
la france du coc vide ce qui les place
dans une position avantageuse pour aller
racheter des fleurons stratégiques chez
nous
le service de l'information stratégique
et de la sécurité économique déclare son
niveau de vigilance
je cite très très élevé et il y a des
exemples récents concret en début
d'année bruno le maire avait dû mettre
son veto face à une menace de rachat de
carrefour par l'entreprise québécoise
couche tard autre exemple le
gouvernement s'était opposé au rachat de
photos nice une pme bordelaise
spécialisée dans les instruments de
vision nocturne par l'américain télé
d'ein bref bercy veille au grain pour
éviter toute perte qui mettrait à mal
les forces économiques du pays et garde
un oeil en particulier sur 4000
entreprises de sa base industrielle et
technologique de défense
en 2020 le ministère de l'économie a
identifié 270 menace de prédation sur
des entreprises stratégiques françaises
et le rythme aurait augmenté puisque
très récemment
geoffrey ses récents urbain affirmé
recevoir une alerte de sécurité
économique par jour